[Música]
o primeiro é um prazer estar aqui e eu
vou compartilhar com vocês
a história desta instituição de crédito
ea pergunta é bastante
é difícil de responder mas eu vou tentar
com bastante carinho respondê-la bom o
meu primeiro tópico fala sobre propósito
tudo na minha vida é movido por
propósito e tem uma frase que eu gosto
bastante de trazer que eu escolhi que
adora estoques que fala sobre onde meus
talentos e paixões se encontram com as
necessidades do mundo vai estar no meu
lugar
e foi assim que eu criei essa
instituição de crédito
mas antes de falar dessa instituição de
crédito minha história começa em 1986
esse é meu pai
nesta foto é meu pai
ele veio para sorocaba e 1986
junto com a minha mãe que está nessa
foto aqui nós somos paranaenses e nós
viemos para o interior dos a de são
paulo do interior do paraná
lá ele era agricultor e de agricultor
ele virou empreendedor e do trabalho no
campo
ele foi para a indústria e depois se
tornou empreendedor e essa foto aqui sou
eu pequenininha e porque eu trouxe essa
foto né
vocês devem estar se perguntando por que
é o único ativo que ele tinha era
família ele não tinha mais nada
então nós viemos pra sorocaba apenas com
os 600 reais de hoje né era isso que nós
tínhamos
então todo mundo
muito né como é que você começou uma
instituição de crédito é você é de
família rica não se casou com um marido
rico
não né então o único ativo que minha
família tinha era família né e 600 reais
e trouxe no bolso para fazer uma compra
do mês quando nós chegamos em sorocaba
eles foram morar numa comunidade e nessa
comunidade como esse bairro era tratado
né
existe um projeto social e esse projeto
social e lhe dava cursos de informática
para jovens carentes e eu fui uma dessas
alunas desse projeto e eu ganhei lá uma
bolsa de estudos
e com essa bolsa de estudos e eu pude
estudar num colégio melhor né então eu
fiz um time uma educação melhor do que
eu tinha quando tinha 16 anos eu li um
livro chamado banqueiro dos pobres e no
decorrer da da minha juventude né eu
ainda sou jovem né e que foi apresentada
como jovem eu tenho 33 anos hoje é eu
tive contato com muitos projetos sociais
e aquele livro que eu li quando tinha 16
anos me inspirou e quando eu é que
estava no projeto pérola eu tive contato
com outra organização social chamada
artemisia e essa organização ela fez um
concurso de planos de negócios e esse
concurso de planos de negócios
ele tinha como objetivo selecionar os
cinco melhores empreendedores
bom gente daini
é junto tudo né juntou a história dos
meus pais que eram empreendedores junto
à leitura desse livro que trazia a
história de um banqueiro que ajudou um
país que não tinha acesso a crédito
o banqueiro dos pobres né que fez muito
com pouco
juntou a minha experiência num projeto
social com informática eu vi aqui tinha
muita gente que muitos jovens que não
tinham acesso à educação eu era uma
delas e com acesso à educação eu pude
acessar muitas coisas e depois de ter
ganhado também esse concurso na camisa
eu criei uma instituição de crédito
focada no empreendedor
isso aconteceu em 2009 e por que o
empreendedor
é assim eu comecei o o projeto inspirado
na minha família mas o brasil é um país
de empreendedores
os números trazem isso então hoje 52
pois 52 milhões de brasileiros são
empreendedores os empregos gerados no
brasil 52% deles vem das pequenas
empresas
então um em cada três pessoas
economicamente ativas são empreendedoras
no brasil hoje
então assim por que não atender
empreendedores com crédito além da
história familiar
os números trouxeram pra mim né mais que
dados não trouxeram uma necessidade
muito atente de atendimento desse
público
e aqui tem a falar as fases de
desenvolvimento do projeto em 2010
nasce a idéia a partir de uma história
familiar em 2011 12 foram os primeiros
anos de operação do pérola e como eu
disse pra vocês né
lá no começo eu não nasci de uma família
que tinha ativos financeiros
a gente veio lá do interior do paraná 1
600 reais pra fazer a primeira compra do
mês
então de onde vem o dinheiro como é que
eu consegui criar essa instituição de
crédito a instituição de crédito foi
criada a partir de muitas premiações que
eu participei
então todo o edital que aparecia eu me
inscrevi a todos absolutamente inclusive
tinham prêmios que eu acho que as
pessoas nem queriam mais me receber
então 2011 2012
eu recebi premiações de editais para
poder emprestar recurso mesmo para as
pessoas
só que em 2013
veio uma fase de muito questionamento
por que porque não existe instituição
que possa depender durante tanto tempo
de premiações e de editais e daí vem uma
grande pergunta é né que inclusive
remete ao tema da apresentação é
possível fazer crédito de maneira justa
no país como criar uma instituição de
crédito focada no microempreendedor
focada nesse público que não têm acesso
a crédito de maneira justa né eu sou
empreendedora eu busco atender o
empreendedor então como é que a gente
une todas essas coisas
além do mais não é o dinheiro estava
acabando das premiações como é que eu
criaria uma ferramenta pra te fã de
financiamento constante
foi aí que em 2013 nasce uma segunda
idéia de transformar essa instituição de
crédito em um fundo de investimento
regulamentado pela cvm bom
naquele momento eu tinha 27 anos
eu comecei a instituição com 24
se antes já era um projeto bastante
complicado para se iniciar com 24 anos
com 27 uma aprovação da cvm parecia
bastante improvável também mas é em 2014
esse fundo foi aprovado para conectar
investidores e empreendedores
investidores que acreditassem no
potencial daqueles empreendedores lá no
começo e empreendedores aqueles 52
milhões de empreendedores que
necessitassem de crédito e assim
aconteceu em 2014
o fundo foi aprovado
nós começamos a operar e daí veio a
crise financeira né
eu acho que todo mundo lembra de algum
episódio complicado de crise financeira
no brasil
e não foi diferente comigo
então quando eu tinha 24 anos
eu era uma jovem eu sou jovem ainda mas
eu era mais jovem e muito sonhadora e eu
acreditava e continua acreditando nas
pessoas mas naquele momento eu achava
que eu não tinha eu tinha problema mas
quando eu vivi a crise financeira
brasileira com uma instituição aprovada
na cvm eu descobri que eu não tinha
problema
eu passei a ter problemas naquele
momento e e de 2015 2017
eu vivi muitas coisas eu vi
empreendedores indo à falência eu vi
empreendedores sendo despejados de suas
casas
eu vi empreendedores é é perdendo suas
coisas pra agiotas e nesse momento nesse
nesses anos nós tínhamos centenas de
empreendedores dentro do fundo aprovadas
e nós tínhamos emprestado milhões de
reais
eu tinha 27 anos bom eu vou até passar
que preciso e depois eu volto né
e assim eu comecei a minha apresentação
falando de propósito porque eu já passei
logo pra essa né nem terminei de falar
depois eu volto pra linha do tempo
porque nesse momento
eu acho que só o propósito segundo jô
mais nada né
e eu defino essa fase da minha vida como
uma montanha uma montanha a ser escalada
mesmo né uma montanha cheia de sombra
o propósito ali né a luz e eu descobri
que pérola realmente vem da dor da ostra
né
e em muitos momentos eu estive
completamente sozinha ea única coisa que
segurou foi o propósito e assim eu
passei e eu tive que tomar uma decisão a
decisão seu continuava com o meu projeto
o separava eu acho que existe é algumas
ilusões de que a vida do empreendedor é
fácil mas não é
a vida do empreendedor é cheia de
desafios né e os empreendedores de
sucesso
ele só tem sucesso se eles realmente são
apaixonados pelo que eles fazem e eu me
considero uma pessoa apaixonada pelo que
eu faço e eu tenho um propósito e isso
que me segurou e quando eu voltei aqui
em 2018
eu decidi que eu ia apoiar
empreendedores que fossem apaixonados
pelo que eles fizessem e que realmente
acreditar sem os seus negócios
e quando eu fiquei sozinha naquela
montanha que não foi uma montanha mas
foi uma sala fiquei com um fundo cheio
de investidor propagar lotado de milhões
de reais para devolver para os
investidores e teve que recompor a minha
equipe
pintei
eu falei não a partir de 2017 dia 27 de
dezembro teve até uma data
eu só vou apoiar empreendedores que
realmente são apaixonados por aquilo que
fazem assim como eu porque o primeiro
crédito que eu dei foi uma pessoa assim
lá em 2009
e esses casos nós são os que me motiva
são os que me fazem acordar de manhã e
trabalhar
são pessoas como o senhor rubens que tem
uma padaria no bairro que trabalha com a
esposa na e que através do pão de cada
dia literalmente né faz com que a
economia gire inclusive o slogam la de
uma das apresentações trazem isso né
são pessoas que fazem a economia girar
e assim eu tenho que me controlar pra
caramba pra não chorar porque eu sempre
chora e hoje eu prometi que eu não vou
chorar não vai voar toda a maquiagem
aqui que eu fiz eu não costumo assentar
gente e aqui
a fabiana também um outro exemplo e
assim como fabiana o senhor rubens
existem milhares de outros
empreendedores que o projecto apoia e
que eu acredito e que eu me vejo neles
eu contei uma história aqui da
construção de uma instituição de crédito
que tem gente lá também existe gente
trabalhando nasceu do sonho de uma
pessoa então assim humanizar as
instituições também é importante talvez
com com o crescimento da tecnologia e
com mais opções de crédito nascendo a
gente possa dar uma democratizada
em tudo isso que que a gente não
concorda né com as altas taxas de juros
que existe no brasil né pra que o
crédito chegue mais barato para o
empreendedor
mas ao mesmo tempo o empreendedor também
precisa fazer um exercício de quanto ele
precisa de dinheiro né o quanto é justo
pra ele de dinheiro também pra consumir
de maneira mais consciente e finalmente
né
como é operar crédito no brasil quantas
instituições de crédito a gente tem hoje
será que a gente não precisa de mais
instituições de crédito pra dar uma
diminuída na concentração das
instituições de crédito então é difícil
pra caramba construir uma instituição de
crédito
eu estou nesse mercado há 10 anos e para
se manter nele não é fácil então exige
muito dinheiro e alguns milhões de reais
para se manter vivo e eu libero uma
instituição pequena então como que é dar
crédito no brasil
na então é todo um ecossistema que se
diria muito mais bate papo talvez por
uma manhã e finalmente né meu sonho de
hoje é contribuir para a criação e
manutenção de uma instituição que seja
justa e que atenda a milhares de
empreendedores que necessitem desse
serviço o serviço justo um serviço de
crédito e que contribua para o
crescimento desse cliente desse
empreendedor que continue gerando renda
já no emprego mas que esse empreendedor
também faço exercício né
assim como a gente faz lá dentro é isso
obrigado